un jour on m'a posé une devinette
et je vais vous la poser aujourd'hui je
clique cette feuille de papier en deux
une fois deux fois trois fois
l'épaisseur du pliage doit maintenant
faire quelque chose comme à mm à votre
avis quelles auraient été les pêcheurs
de se plier âge si j'allais plier cette
feuille de papier en 2 42 x 1 cm 10 cm 1
m
écoutez votre intuition prenez trois
secondes pour y penser
et ben si j'avais plier cette feuille de
papier en de 42 fois son épaisseur
aurait dépassé la distance entre la
terre et la lune et je vous donne cet
exemple pour vous montrer à quel point
le cerveau humain n'est pas fait pour
estimer les croissances exponentielles
les croissance in r ça va
combien font 2 + 2 42 x 84 par contre
les croissances exponentielles
combien font deux fois 2 42 x 4 mille
milliards
et c'est cela qui nous empêche de
l'appréhender naturellement certains
grands changements notre époque comme la
croissance des entreprises innovantes
aujourd'hui alors vous savez c'est assez
risqué de commencer un talk en parant
exponentielle j'entends par là d'un coup
aux filières tout seul il son micro dans
une salle vide
j'en ai conscience honnêtement tous ces
trucs qu'on a appris à l'école est
exponentielle théorème de thalès de
pythagore
c'est sympa comme une gastro on n'a
qu'une seule envie que ça s'arrête
sérieusement les trois quarts des choses
qu'on a appris à l'école ne nous servent
jamais à rien prenez justement le
théorème de thalès qui a déjà réutiliser
le théorème de thalès depuis qu'il a
quitté l'école lever la main
voilà tout est dit il m'avait fait
souffrir le théorème de thalès je
m'étais premier quand j'étais collégien
qu'un jour je me le ferais publiquement
ces faits donne
mais ceci dit à ma grande surprise les
exponentielle elles reviennent au goût
du jour du moins dans l'entrepreneuriat
vous êtes vous déjà demandé pourquoi les
cinq plus grandes entreprises au monde
avait tout moins de 50 ans ce soit apple
google microsoft amazon facebook
et bien aujourd'hui nous allons
découvrir ensemble pourquoi les
entreprises technologiques se mettent à
grossir aussi vite est atteinte de telle
valorisation à commencer par un exemple
le mylenium tour de madonna en 2008
rien ne vous choque alors tout le monde
prend des photos
c'est normal on les comprend mais ceci
dit pas un seul smartphone et pour cause
le premier smartphone iphone a été
commercialisé moins d'un an auparavant
et dix ans après ces deux milliards de
personnes qui utilisent quotidiennement
un smartphone et ça c'est une vitesse de
croissance typique des entreprises
aujourd'hui je me suis passionné pour ce
sujet il ya sept ans j'étais chercheur
j'adorais ça et j'ai tout plaqué parce
que n'avancez pas enfin si ça avance et
de manière linéaire la carrière
académique
vous savez où sera votre bureau dont 20
ans personnellement la plus grande
angoisse
alors j'ai tout balancer pour aller
créer me lancer dans l'entrepreneuriat
essayez de goûter un peu séduit
exponentielle cette vie pleine de
surprises et j'étais servir surtout en
termes de surprise d'ailleurs on y
reviendra peut-être j'ai créé une
entreprise un peu spécial un mix entre
un laboratoire de recherche privée et
une pouponnière d'entreprise depuis 2011
sa création nous avons créé une petite
dizaine d'entreprises innovantes en
biotechnologies en france toutes issues
de nos recherches et les gens me
demandent souvent alors pourquoi créer
autant d'entreprises en france
et bien parce que je suis persuadé
qu'une révolution très rapide est en
cours dans le domaine des
biotechnologies et j'aimerais bien que
cette fois ci mon pays en fassent partie
pas comme la révolution précédent dans
les télécommunications
vous savez éviter le plan minitel contre
internet
awake parce que je suis également
convaincu que rater deux révolutions
technologiques d'affilée et s'imaginer
qu'on va rester une grande puissance
mais pour moi c'est un peu comme un raté
deux fois son bac et penser qu'on va
rentrer à polytechnique c'est possible
il faut avoir la foi quand même or la
france est un pays qui m'a tout donné à
moi comme à tous mes associés j'étais
vraiment pas un élève brillant j'étais
très dyslexiques ma maîtresse voulait
même pas me faire passer en sixième
compte pas la tête de mes parents
d'ailleurs
et pourtant la france m'a payé mes
études jusqu'à la fin du doctorat
sérieusement quel autre pays fait ça
pareillement quand j'ai créé ma première
entreprise en 2011 la moitié des
financements et vu l'état français et
comme disait ma grand mère que j'aimais
beaucoup
il ne faut pas cracher dans la main qui
nous a nourris par forcément intérêt à
me le dire celles qui ne les résout pas
les ceci dit je trouve que son point de
vue et est plein de bon sens et du coup
si je suis là aujourd'hui devant vous
c'est aussi pour vous dire que la france
est peut-être aujourd'hui le meilleur
pays au monde pour créer une start up
innovantes des supers ingénieurs des
supers laboratoire de recherche une
super fiscalité des novations alors
nouveau aux auto censurés par le
momentum est parfait pour créer une
start up en france et si vous avez un
doute ou encore mieux une grosse envie
d'entreprendre et bien contacté mois sur
linkedin ou ailleurs écrivez-moi en iran
discuter autour d'un café autour d'un
verre de vin
j'adore mon boulot c'est formidable les
renault à nos moutons parce qu'il se
passe quand même un drôle de truc dans
l'entrepreneuriat aujourd'hui prenons
tesla car une entreprise automobile
américaine créée il ya 14 ans font des
voitures électriques et qui fait encore
600 millions d'euros de pair
et qui pourtant est devenue l'année
dernière en terme de valorisation la
plus grosse entreprise automobile
américaine plus que ford plus que
general motors et ses deux cent mille
personnes et ses 110 ans d'existence et
ce phénomène est encore plus intense
dans le domaine des start-up software
celles qui font des logiciels comme moi
doivent par exemple comme nous le
rappelle laurent alexandre qui est un
multi entrepreneur qui entre autres
fondés doctissimo comment est il
possible que les 55 employés douanes zap
et pu créer en quatre ans une entreprise
revendue 10 7 milliards d'euros
c'est plus que xerox et 143 milles
personnes qui bossent pendant 110 ans
alors certains diront que j'en ferais à
chaque fort en tout cas c'est parce que
la finance est devenue folle alors oui
peut-être pas exclu mais ceci dit les
gens extrêmement riche qui investissent
et rachète ces entreprises ne sont pas
devenus extrêmement riche en faisant les
mauvais investissements non il doit y
avoir quelque chose et il ya quelque
chose
ce quelque chose c'est trois révolutions
synergique qui ont lieu au cours des
deux dernières décennies et qui ont
profondément changé la vitesse de
croissance de nos entreprises et la
manière dont nous percevons leur valeur
la première évolution et financières
avec la naissance dans les années 70
mais surtout l'énorme boom dans les
années 90 des vins chuck capitalisme
énorme boum a eu lieu avec le le boom
d'internet en l'occurrence contrairement
aux banques qui vous prêtent de l'argent
lorsque vous êtes entrepreneur dans le
but d'être remboursé quelques années
après avec intérêt un venture
capitalists achètent des actions de
votre entreprise des parties de votre
entreprise dans le but de les revendre
un peu plus tard un meilleur prix et la
seule chose que vous demande 1,25
capitaliste en retour c'est une chance
de pouvoir faire un jackpot et certains
pionniers du domaine l'ont eu
si on prend la personne derrière moi à
côté de steve jobs qui s'appelle mike
may recul 1 il a investi en 1976
deux cent cinquante mille euros dans
apple lors de son introduction en bourse
id est né
30 pour son entreprise entreprise qui
vous aujourd'hui 800 milliards d'euros
notez que le deuxième chiffre est près
de 12 millions de fois plus gros que le
premier jouait déjà chez certains
d'entre vous un des yeux qui se met à
briller
vous imaginez peut-être déjà être le
troisième co fondateur d'apple à côté de
steve jobs et wozniak
quelle aventure frais formidable mais
ceci dit ne prenait pas sa place trop
vite parce qu'il y avait vraiment un
troisième co fondateur d'apple en
l'occurrence il s'appelait ronald wayne
s'appelle toujours d'ailleurs il a
encore envie mais il a quitté
l'entreprise quelques mois avant
l'arrivée de mike markkula de venture
capitalists et l'a revendu l'intégralité
de ses actions 10% d'apple pour 800
dollars 800 dollars 800 milliards
paul ceci dit au moins j'ai récupéré mon
public adoré
on peut continuer avant quand
l'entrepreneur avait besoin d'argent ils
allaient voir la banque
quand je vous le disais la banque prête
de l'argent à l'entrepreneur dont le but
d'être remboursé quelques années après
avec intérêt pour être sûr d'être
remboursé
la banque demande en entrepreneur une
rentabilité récurrente une bonne
solidité financière et dans ce cas de
l'entrepreneur et forcé d'orienter sa
stratégie d'entreprise sur la
rentabilité à court terme et la création
d'actifs tangibles comme l'achat de
bâtiments ou de ma chaîne youtube quoi
que ce soit le venture capitalists lui
accepte de tout perdre quand la
possibilité de toucher le jackpot lorsqu
il revendra ses actions une petite
dizaine d'années après dans ce cadre il
n'a que faire de la rentabilité à court
terme ce qui compte pour lui c'est la
taille de l'entreprise lorsqu'il
revendre à ses actions dans ce cas
l'entrepreneur n'a pas du tout besoin de
focaliser sur la rentabilité à court
terme il peut focaliser sur son
expansion mondiale et sa croissance à
long terme il n'a pas elle est rentable
pour ça et d'ailleurs même en cas
d'opportunité d'hypercroissance par
exemple vous avez besoin d'énormément
d'argent pour adresser un nouveau marché
il suffit de retourner voir vos
investisseurs on trouve
toujours des vengeurs capitaliste qui
sont d'accord pour mettre de l'argent
dans les boîtes qui grossissent plus
vite que prévu et d'ailleurs si votre
boîte est financé par venture
capitalists devenir rentable peut
devenir une très mauvaise nouvelle
bizarrement cela peut vouloir dire que
vous n'avez plus aucun marché
d'envergure pour réinvestir votre argent
cela veut dire que votre start up a
atteint son plateau de chiffre
d'affaires on voit ici comme un simple
changement dans les méthodes de
financement a profondément changé la
vitesse de croissance de nos entreprises
ont leur permettant de grossir
exponentiellement sans avoir besoin
d'être profitable mais cela a également
changé la manière dont nous percevons
leur valeur non plus basée sur un
multiple de la rentabilité de
l'entreprise
mais sur la taille estimée de
l'entreprise une petite dizaine d'années
après la deuxième révolution dont je
vous parlais la connaissez tous elle est
technologique
c'est le web alors le web nous apporte
deux choses tout d'abord la possibilité
de tester une idée immédiatement avant
même de faire la r&d avec une simple
page web et ça change tout de base et
ses développements sur des faits et non
plus des hypothèses avant qu'un
entrepreneur du moins jeunes
entrepreneurs avaient une idée est bien
développer son produit neuf fois sur dix
safari complètement le marché voulait
pas du produit à chaque fois qu'on monte
une boîte on est persuadé d'avoir une
super idée à un super plan mais rien ne
se passe jamais comme prévu à
l'entrepreneuriat vous pouvez me croire
et d'ailleurs ce sujet j'ai la citation
qui je trouve l'illustrent bien d'un
philosophe américain la seconde moitié
du 20e siècle
mike tyson qui disait tout le monde a un
plan en tête
enfin jusqu'à ce qu'il prenne mon poing
dans la gueule eh ben ça résume
extrêmement bien ce que ressent
entrepreneurs lors du premier contact
marché du moins avant l'arrivée du web
parce qu'aujourd'hui quand vous êtes
entrepreneur avec vous avez une idée que
vous faites une page web et vous essayez
de vendre votre
puis vous adaptez votre offre on
essayait de trouver le produit qui se
vend le mieux
plus à la fin vous développer le produit
qui s'est le mieux vendu la deuxième
chose que nous apporte le web
similairement c'est la possibilité avec
une simple page web
une fois que le produit développé de
communiquer immédiatement au niveau
mondial avant quand vous les communiquer
sur votre produit
vous devez faire des pubs à la télé des
compacts dans les journaux des campagnes
à la radio c'était lens était cher
c'était terriblement locale c'était un
cauchemar
aujourd'hui vous faites une page web et
vous pouvez vendre notre produit sur
toute la planète et ça a tout changé de
ne plus être limité par la taille de son
marché national et ceci dit pour les
plus réguliers d'entre vous me direz
pour ça on a besoin d'une troisième
révolution
et oui et cette troisième révolution et
géoéconomique c'est la mondialisation de
la distribution en moins deux décennies
l'intégralité de la chaîne de
distribution et et mondialisée si vous
prenez la première entreprise en 2011
mon premier client était france est mon
deuxième client était néo zélandais aux
antipodes
aujourd'hui par exemple avec amazon vous
pouvez vendre aussi bien de votre pays
d'origine qu'à l'autre bout de la
planète s'est complètement transparent
et c'est toute la chaîne de distribution
qui a été mondialisée ce soit les avions
cargo fedex les porte containers
questionne les océans parle même pas des
simplifications douanière échange
automatique de 2010 des accords de libre
échange
c'est devenu presque trop facile presque
aussi dit mais si on peut quand même
noter qu'il est quand même aujourd'hui
plus facile de vente sur toute la
planète que de vente dans toute la
france dans les années 70 alors on l'a
vu trois révolutions ont profondément
changé la vitesse de croissance de nos
entreprises et la manière dont nous
percevons leur valeur une révolution
financière de 25 capitalisme qui permet
aux entreprises de grossir de manière
exponentielle sans avoir besoin d'être
profitable
une révolution technologique et
géoéconomique le web et la
mondialisation la distribution qui nous
permette devants dès le premier jour au
niveau mondial et qui du coup ainsi
encore augmenter la vitesse de
croissance est exponentielle
je pense que vous comprenez mieux du
moins j'espère maintenant pourquoi les
cinq plus grandes entreprises de la
planète ont toutes moins de 50 ans pour
une bonne raison c'est que le jeu dicton
rien ne sert de courir il faut partir à
point
eh bien il marche plus du tout c'est une
entreprise qui grossit linéairement
depuis deux siècles n'a aucune chance
contre une entreprise qui grossit
exponentiellement pendant une ou deux
décennies on l'a vu c'est la force
exponentielle même si vous commencez
avec un chiffre d'affaires d'1 euro par
an si vous le doublé tous les six mois
au bout de 25 ans vous aurez un chiffre
d'affaires d'un million milliards
d'euros par an plus que le pib mondial
si vous arrivez à financer une
croissance exponentielle pendant une ou
deux décennies et débenture capitaliste
par exemple vous serez limité par la
taille de notre planète
alors maintenant que vous savez que tout
est possible qu'il n'y a strictement
aucune limite à ce qu'un individu peut
apporter au monde ont une ou deux
décennies
qu'allez vous faire on n'a qu'une seule
vie comme disait gandhi soyez le
changement que vous voulez voir dans le
monde je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]